طابع يومكم واهلا بكم في ساعه اخباريه
جديده نخصص معظمها لتغطيه المشهد بالسودان
وهذه العناوين
طائرات الجيش تحلق في سماء الخرطوم والدعم
السريع يتهمه بقصف تمركزات عناصره في
الولايات
الجيش السوداني يعلن استمرار عمليات اجلاء
الرعايه الاجانب من قاعده وادي سيدنا رغم
التحضيرات الامنيه
الشرطه السودانيه تنشر قوات الاحتياط
المركز لحفظ الانف في الخرطوم مع تزايد
عمليات النهب وسرقه
وفي الساعه الاخباريه ايضا
اوكرانيا تقول ان قواتها لا تزال تحتفظ
باحدى طرق الامداد الرئيسيه في بخموت
رغم الهدنه الانسانيه المعلنه لا تزال
اشتباكات مستمره حيث تجددت في مدن سودانيه
عده من بينها في محيط القياده العامه
والخرطوم بحري فيما تبادل الجيش والدعم
السريع الاتهامات مجددا بشان انتهاك
الهدنه المعلنه ياتي ذلك فيما تتفاقم
الاوضاع الطبيه حيث دعا الهلال الاحمر دعا
المنظمات الدوليه لتقديم مساعداتها
العاجله
مع دخول المعارك بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع اسبوعها الثالث تجددت الاشتباكات
حيث تشهد منطقتا المهندسين وصالحه
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله وقصفا
بالطيران بحسب مراسل العربيه وبحسب شهود
عياننا الحلفايه شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري
بدا الجيش في نشر وحداته والقيام بعمليات
تمشيط بعد معارك عنيفه شهدتها المنطقه هذا
وتجددويا انفجارات واصوات اطلاق نار في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش
الان
الحلفايه
هو هذا الجيش
تنشيط ضخمه جدا
وهذا ضخمه جدا الان
وهو ضخمه جدا
وضخمه جدا
من الجيش
من جانبي اتهم الجيش السوداني استمرار
قوات الدعم السريع في انتهاك الهدنه
المعلنه من خلال عمليات تحشيدا تقوم بها
غرب العاصمه الخرطوم الجيش دان استمرار
القصف العشوائي وعمليات نهب الممتلكات بما
فيها البنوك ومنازل المواطنين وقال بيان
للجيش ان قوات الدعم السريع حولت مستشفى
شرق قنديل الى ثكنه ومركز قياده لعملياتها
البيان اكد على استمرار الجيش في تهيئه
الظروف المناسبه لنزول الشرطه تدريجيا الى
الشوارع
[موسيقى]
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت هي الاخرى الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من مناطق
الخرطوم بالمدافع وطائرات بيان دعم السريع
اشار الى طائرات الجيش ما تزال تحلق في
سما الخرطوم وتنتهك الهدنه الدعم السريع
قال ان الجيش يستعد لشن هجوم في العاصمه
الخرطوم ومدينه حلفايا وان درمان وبحره
هذا وشهدت الخرطوم غارات جويه واطلاق نار
متبادل بين الجيش وقوه دعم السريع مع دخول
المعارك اسبوع الثالث
السودان اسبوع ثالث من القتال
مخاوف من ان يؤدي الصراع الى حرب طويله
الامد
صراع انفجر منتصف ابريل ولم يهدا بعد
طرف صراعي الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
قرر مواجهه بالسلاح والتبادل الاتهامات
اعلاميا
حصيله كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
الاف الفارينه الى دول الجوار وعمليات
اجلاء كبيره ومستمره
واستظروف انسانيه صعبه
هدنه معلنه وجهود دوليه لوقف القتال
لكن اعمده الدخان لم تغب عن سماء الخرطوم
نذهب الان الى الخرطوم معنا من هناك مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي سالم مرحبا بك معنا
في هذه الساعه الاخباريه التي نخصص جلها
لتطورات الوضع في السودان هل عادت
الاشتباكات بين الاطراف المتحاربه في
العاصمه السودانيه اما زال الهدوء والهدوء
الحذر سيد الموقف
نعم هنا في الخرطوم هناك هدوء حذر في
المناطق القريبه من الجهه المركزيه او
المنطقه المركزيه لمدينه الخرطومه ونقص
الامم مطار الخرطوم الدولي وكذلك
ايضا محيط القياده العامه للجيش حتى القصر
الرئاسي هناك في هذه اللحظات فقط تجددت
الاشتباكات في صباح اليوم في مناطق في ام
درمان وهي المهندسين ومحيط هذه المنطقه
بالاضافه الى منطقه صالحه منذ الامس وحتى
الصباح اليوم بقيه المناطق تشهد هدوءا
نسبيا هناك حركه للمواطنين ايضا نسبيه في
مناطق متفرقه
قبل قليل ايضا سمعنا اصوات للرصاص فقط في
مناطق متفرقه ومتقطعه في الخرطوم
طيب سالم بالحديث عن ام درمان يعني
اندرمان معروفه منطقه كبيره بالتالي هل
يمكن القول بان الاشتباكات وان كانت وانت
تتم هي بالتالي محدوده متفرقه رغم حدتها
الان
تشهد مناطق الاشتباكات فيها محدوده او
محدده للغايه هي مناطق محدده ظلت تتجدد
فيها الاشتباكات منذ بدء هذه الاشتباكات
في اسبوعين وحتى دخلنا في الاسبوع الثالث
الان في منطقه محيط المهندسين منطقه محيطه
لاذاعه والتلفزيون كذلك وكذلك منطقه
الصالحه في هذه المناطق تتجدد الاشتباكات
غالبا عدا انه في بدايه الاشتباكات كانت
هنالك يعني في المعسكر معسكر قدري والذي
يقع الشمال وقد كان حرره الجيش السوداني
وتم قصفه بالطيران واعلن الجيش السوداني
سيطرته التامه على هذا المعسكر وما زال
الجيش السوداني مسيطرا على هذا المعسكر
حتى هذه اللحظات
مناوشات تكون على جسر الحلفايه الذي ليس
ببعيد من هذا المعسكر المعسكر هذا ابرز ما
يكون في ام درمان وتتكرر فيه الاشتباكات
منطقه الحلفايه بالامس شهدت اشتباكا عنيفا
لكن اع اده الهدوء الى هذه المنطقه صباح
اليوم والان انتشرت قوات الجيش في تلك
المنطقه منطقه الحلفايه وذكر شهود عيانا
انه الجيش بدا في تمشيط هذه المنطقه منطقه
الحلفايه شمال بحري وشمال طيب ما قصه
الفيديوهات التي تم تداولها حول اندلاع
حريق في البنك المركزي السوداني هل تكشفت
اي تفاصيل جديده اذا ذلك
هذه الصور ليست للبنك المركزي سرعه
الرئيسي الفرع الرئيسي للبنك المركزي وهو
في
صحه تامه وسلامه تامه عفوا في سلامه تامه
لم يتعرض لاي اعتداء او ضرب هذه هي واحد
فروع البنك المركزي وهذا الفرع ليس ببعيد
من القياده العامه للجيش قريب جدا من
القياده العامه للجيش في هذه المنطقه
بالضبط ولكن الفيديو يعني ان صح فهو في
هذه المنطقه وليس للبنك المركزي الفرع
الرئيسي الذي هو في المغرب وانما هو لفرع
من البنك المركزي في محيط
القياده العامه للجيش السوداني طيب سالم
اليوم كيف هي حركه المواطنين اليوميه هل
مثلا بعد خروج قوات الشرطه لتامين اسواق
محل تجاريه اعطاهم دافعا ولو قليل
الاطمئنان
نعم هناك بيان صدر من الشرطه السودانيه
تحدثت فيه الشرطه عن انها تريد
انها انزلت فصيل من فصائل تتبع للشرطه وهي
شرطه الاحتياطي المركزي وان القوه
ستكون او هدفها الرئيسي تحقيق الامن
وسلامه المنشات وكذلك تامين ممتلكات
المواطنين هذا هو الهدف الرئيسي لهذه
القوه التي بدات في الامس في النزول
والجيش السوداني كان قد قال ان نزول
الشرطه سيكون تدريجيا وستتم تهيئه الاجواء
لنزول الشرطه تدريجيا في العاصمه الخرطوم
ربما هناك خطه تدرس الان من الجيش والشرطه
في مساله تامين لان الشكاوى تكررت والفتره
طارت كذلك في مساله النهضه الممتلكات
والسرقات التي تتكرر يوميا من المواطنين
وحتى الاسواق تطال محال التجاريه تطال
المواطنين في بيوتهم ومنازلهم هذه الامور
تدفع الى نزول الشرطه من اجل تحقيق
التامين للمواطنين وللممتلكات كذلك
وفق المراقبات هل فعلا بدات
تخف حده الاشتباكات بين الطرفين يوما بعد
يوم الى حين وصلنا الى هذا اليوم في
الاسبوع الثالث منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات
بالضبط هذا ما يحدث الان ان حده
الاشتباكات تقل كذلك الاصوات ليست كما
كانت في السابق بالنسبه للمدافع واستخدام
الاسلحه باشكالها وانواعها المختلفه حتى
تحلق الطيران لم يعد كما كان في السابق
يعني قلت حده هذا الامر عدا في مناطق
معينه او مناطق بعينها كان في السابق هذا
الامر على عام ولايه الخرطوم او يشمل كل
ولايات الخرطوم بمدنها الثلاث الان اصبحت
المناطق التي تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات
معروفه محدده تتجدد فيها الاشتباكات بين
الفين والاخرى حتى عدد الساعات التي تكون
فيها الاشتباكات هي اقل عدد الساعات التي
تختفي في هذه الاصوات هي اكثر وربما هنالك
تدرج في مساله الهدنه بين هدنه وهنه
ونشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه سامر سالم
اكد الجيش مواصله اجلال رعايه دول اجنبيه
من قاعده وادي سيدنا الجويه دون تهديدات
مع استمرار المواجهات المسلحه مع قوات
الدعم السريع قبل ذلك اوقفت كل من مصر
وامريكا وبريطانيا عمليات اجلاء المواطنين
من مطار قاعده وادي سيدنا لاسباب امنيه
واحثت وزاره الخارجيه المصريه في بيان
حفله الموجودين في القاعده على مغادرتها
في اقرب فرصه متاحه كما حضرت السفاره
الامريكيه في الخرطوم حضرت مواطنيها من
التوجه لمطار وادي سيدنا بسبب تصاعد
التهديد الامن والعنف في المطار ومحيطه
وعلى خلفيه المواجهات المسلحه المستمره
بدا موظفون في ولايه الخرطوم عطله رسميه
حتى اشعار اخر وذلك بسبب ظروف الامنيه
التي تعيشها البلاد ولا تشمل العطله غرف
اداره الازمه والمرافق الخدميه الحيويه
في سياق متصل اعلنت ولايه القضارف ونهر
النيل في السودان حاله طوارئ لمواجهه
تداعيات الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا في
البلاد حيث امر والي القضارف باعلان حاله
الطوارئ لمده شهر مؤكدا ان من يخالف
الاوامر يعرض نفسه للغرامه او السجن هذا
واعلن والي نهر النيل ايضا حاله طوارئ
بالبلايه ووجه الجهات المختصه بتنفيذ
الامر وفق وسائل على محليه
اما في ولايه غرب دارفور اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء حصره 94 وفاه جراء الاشتباكات في
مدينه الجنينه قبل ذلك اعلن الجيش
السوداني في بيان ان لجنه امن الولايه
نجحت بالحد من التوتر القبلي وان الشرطه
الاحتياط تفتح تدريجيا مناطق في جنوب
الخرطوم الجيش السوداني اشار في بيانه الى
ان الموقف العمليات مستقر في جميع المناطق
العسكريه بالبلاد مؤكدا استمرار بعض الدول
باجراء رعاياها من الخرطوم وبورتسودان
اظهر مقطع فيديو انتشر عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لحظه فيرار طلاب من جامعه
الخرطوم من صوت اطلاق النار عند احد
المداخل
[تصفيق]
اكدت الشرطه السودانيه ان قوات الاحتياط
المركزي فصيل تابع لها وتم الدفع به
للشوارع لتامين الاسواق وممتلكات
المواطنين وشددت على ان من يقودها خرجوا
كليه الشرطه والقانون قالت الشرطه ردا على
الدعم السريع في البيان قالت انه لا وجود
للامن الشعبي في قوات الاحتياط المركزي
واكده بان مقر البنك المركزي الرئيسي لم
يتعرض لاي هجوم وان الحريق الذي تم
الاعلان عنه يعود لاحد فروع البنك
وحول جهود السعوديه في عمليات الاجلال
مستمره من السودان يستمر الجسر الجوي في
تنفيذ خطته في اجراء الرعايه من جنسيه
مختلفه نحو قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
في مدينه جده هذا وقد وصلت اليوم الى
القاعده طائر عسكريه تابعه للقوات الجويه
السعوديه حيث افاد مراسل العربيه بان
طائره سعوديه اجلى 82 شخصا بينهم 45
سعوديا من بورتسودان الى ميناء جده
نذهب الان الى سلطان السلمي مراسل العربيه
من قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده سلطان
مرحبا بك معنا كيف تمضي عمليات انزال
الفارين من المعارك المحتدمه حتى هذه
الساعه في السودان الى جده وصولا
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
بالفعل وصلت الان سفينه جلاله الملك
الدرعيه التي وصلت من ميناء بورت السودان
في رحله استغرقت 10 ساعات من ميناء
بورتسودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده وها هي الان في محاوله للرسوم هنا
على الرصيف البحري الخاص بقاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه بجده وعلى متنها 52 شخص من
خمسه جنسيات من ضمنهم عشره اشخاص من سلطنه
عمان وامريكي واحد تنوعت الجنسيات بين
الجنسيه الامريكيه والجنسيه العمانيه
والجنسيه النيباليه والباكستانيه
والسودانيه تم اجلاها هؤلاء الرعايه من
شرقي السودان وتحديدا من مدينه بورد
السودان استغرقت هذه الرحله قرابه عشره
الساعات لا تزال عمليات الاجلاء السعوديه
مستمره منذ بدء الفوضى او بدء النزاح
هنالك في السودان منذ ايام نت هذه الرحله
رقم 13 التي ترسو هنا في قاعده او على
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجد نتحدث عن
ارقام تلامس الخمسه الاف شخص قامت السلطات
السعوديه باجلائهم منذ بدا عمليات الاجلاء
من السودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده وكذلك الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه بجده وصلت الان هذه هي الرحله على
متنها كما ذكرنا 52 شخص عبر السفينه
التابعه للقوات الملكيه البحريه السعوديه
وهي الرحله رقم 12 هذه هي سفينه جلاله
الملك الجبيل التي تعمل القوات البحريه
السعوديه على عمليات الاجلاء من بناء
بورتسودان طوال الايام الماضيه ايضا من
المتوقع خلال الساعات القادمه ان تصل كذلك
رحله اخرى على متنها رعايه باختلاف
جنسيتهم سوف تقوم بقوات البحريه السعوديه
بنقل هذا تحدثنا عن يوم امس كان عن اكبر
عمليه اجلاء تمت منذ
البارحه في مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي
بجده اكثر من 229 مواطن هندي سافروا او
غادروا الى بلادهم وتحديدا الى مدينه
بنغالير الهنديه عبر طائره ايرباص 321
تابع الخطوط الجويه الهنديه وقبل ذلك
الرعايه الصينيين نتحدث عن 347 مواطن صيني
ايضا غادروا الى العاصمه الصينيه بكين عبر
طائره بوينج تربل سفن نتحدث عن اعداد كبير
غادروا الى بلدانهم بعد ان وصلوا الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه بجده بعد رحله
قادمه من ميناء بورت السودان كعمليات
اجلاء من مستمره من المتوقع خلال يومين
القادمين ان تزداد الاعداد بشكل كبير
لهؤلاء الرعايه في
سمار عمليات الاجلاء من قبل السلطات
السعوديه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
بجده وحتى الى قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه
دقائق بسيطه وسوف يتم تركيب السلم الخاص
بالسفينه حتى
نحن السلطان نتابع معكم هذه الصور
وبالتاكيد سنعود اليك لكل ما هو جديد
ومتعلق في عمليات وصول الرعايه من جنسيات
مختلفه من بورتسودان وصولا الى موانئ جده
والى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
شكرا سلطان السلمي حتى هذه اللحظه
الى الحدود المصريه السودانيه اظهرت صور
الاقمار الصناعيه اصطاف عشرات الحافلات
على معبر ارجين الحدودي حيث تحمل الفرين
من النزاع الدائر في السودان اظهرت الصور
ازدحاما على المعبر في انتظار عبور
الحافلات الى الطرف المصري
نذهب اذا الى معبر ارجينا على الحدود
المصريه السودانيه معنى من هناك مراسل
عربيه احمد عثمان احمد مرحبا بك معنا في
سياق هذه التغطيه كيف يتم تنظيم واستيعاب
هذه الاعداد الهائله للذين يرغبون بعبور
الحدود السودانيه المصريه
مرحبا بكم بالفعل كما ذكرتي ربما بسبب هذا
الزحام الشديد وهذا التقدس غير المتوقع
ربما شاهدنا خلال اليومين الماضيين عمليه
نقل الكثير من
القادمين من السودان والطلب منهم بان
يتوجهوا الى المنفذ البري الاخر وهو منفذ
قسطل هذا المنفذ يعني ربما تكون عمليه
المرور في بالتوازي مع من الارجلين محاوله
لتخسيس الضغط على منفذ ارجينا الذي شهد
تكدسا كبيرا منذ بدايه الازمه ومنذ اندلاع
الاشتباكات المسلحه في السودان هي محاوله
للتخفيف من هذا المنفذ عن طريق منفذ قسطل
عن طريق منفذ قسطل تتم نفس الاجراءات ولكن
المختلف بانه حين تمر حافلات او القادمين
من السودان عبر الحدود المصريه بعد انتهاء
الاجراءات والتفتيش وغيرها تتم يتم
الانتقال بالحافلات لمده 60 كيلو متر ثم
التوجه بعد ذلك عن طريق
العبارات انيليه الى مدينه ابو سمبل التي
تبعد عن مدينه او عن الحدود او الخط
الثاني والعشرين الذي يفصل ما بين مصر
والسودان حوالي 150 كيلو متر ومنها يتم
التحرك مره اخرى من خلال الحافلات الى
مدينه اسوان او الى القاهره مثلها مثل
باقي الرحلات التي رايناها تنطلق من منفذ
ارجينا الى كل من اسوان والقاهره طيب احمد
هل فعلا اعداد السودانيين اكبر من اعداد
المصريين الذين دخلوا معبر ارجين وهذه
نقطه مهمه تجد الاشاره اليها
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد اذا نحن نتحدث عن
الارقام والاحصائيات التي تصدر تباعا من
قبل وزاره الخارجيه المصريه ربما حتى امس
نحن نتحدث عن ربما 5000 مصري يعني رقم
مقابل له الزياده ولكن نتحدث عن اربع عشر
الاف سوداني يعني هذه الارقام التي تاتي
بحسب الاحصائيات في الرسميه تستطيع ان
تتحدث ربما بان هذا المعدل قد يستمر طويلا
ولكن هناك العديد حتى ممن نراه في بانفسنا
خلال الايام الماضيه مما رايناها بانفسنا
وسجلنا معهم النسبه الاكبر هي من
السودانيين القادمين من الخرطوم اذا ما
قارنت الكثير من المسلمين تم اجلاءهم ايضا
خلال الايام الماضيه عن طريق الطيران
العسكري يعني قبل ان يتم تغيير هذا المسار
خلال يعني امس تم الاعلام بانه مطار وادي
سيدنا يعني تم تغيير ثقه المسارات ولكن
خلال الايام الماضيه سيدنا خروج او اجلاء
العديد من
المسلمين والذ
ين عجزوا بسبب ظروف الاشتباكات من الوصول
الى المراكز البريه تم ارسال عدد من
الطائرات العسكريه لاجلائهم من السودان من
عدد من المطارات العسكريه هناك احمد اي
انباع عن محاولات تسلل لاي عناصر خطيره او
حالات مشتبه بها عبر الحدود
يعني حتى الان حتى الان لا توجد اي
معلومات بالتاكيد يعني هناك مراقبه على
على مدار الساعه لاي محاولات تسلل هذه
المنطقه ومنذ سنوات وهذه الخط المعروف
بالخط الثاني العشرين والذي يشكل خط حدودي
عرض ما بين
على مدار السنوات والعقود الماضيه كان
ملازا للكثير من الارهابيين وبالتاكيد
هناك كفار امني على
مدار الظروف العاديه ليس فقط للعناصر
الارهابيه سواء التابعه للاخوان او حسم
وغيرها هناك يعني تحذير من ان يكون ما
يحدث
محاوله من قبل تنظيمات مثل داعش والقاعده
وغيرها من التنظيمات الارهابيه التي تحاول
ان تنشط وتنتقد ربما من سوريا والعراق او
من القمه الى هذه المنطقه منطقه وادي
النيل وبالتاكيد هناك يعني مراقبه مصريه
صارمه فيما يتعلق بالحدود البريه لمنع
تسلل هذه العناصر شكرا جزيلا لك حتى هذه
اللحظات من معبر ارجين على الحدود المصريه
السودانيه مراسل عربيه احمد عثمان
حذر رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد
الله حمدوك من ان النزاع في السودان قد
يتفاقم الى احدى اسوا الحروب الاهليه في
العالم في حال لم يتم وضع حد له واعتبر ان
ذلك سيشكل كابوسا للعالم وستكون له
تداعيات كبيره راح حمدوك ان نزاع الحالي
عباره عن حرب لا معنى لها مؤكدا ان لا احد
سيخرج منها منتصرا
في الاثناء قال المتحدث الرسمي لقوى
الحريه والتغيير قال للعربيه ان القوى
السياسيه تتواصل مع اطراف دوليه واطراف
عسكريه في الداخل للتفاوض والوصول الى حل
للازمه لانه نحن على تواصل
الداخل
للنقاش معهم حول يعني ما يمكن ان يتم من
تفاوض لانهاء هذه الازمه بالتالي هم ابدو
الموافقه وهذا معلوم بالتالي نعتقد انه
الام ما يدور لطالما انه الطرفين وافقوا
على الحوار يبقى استمرار المعارك واضح انه
هو لتحسين الموقف على الارض
نذهب الى الخرطوم معنا من هناك رئيس تحرير
صحيفه التيار عثمان مرغني اهلا بك استاذ
عثمان معنا في سياق هذه التغطيه رئيس
الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله حمدو
يتوقع كابوسا في العالم اذا لم يتوقف هذا
الصراع في الوقت الذي يقول فيه المبعوث
الاممي ويتحدث عن رسلي انفتاح الجانبين
على المحادثات بالتالي كيف يمكن تفسير
المشهد اليوم في السودان
نعم يعني هو ما قاله الدكتور عبد الله
حمدوك رئيس الوزراء السابق هو في باب
التوقعات بمعنى ان السيناريوه ينفتح على
مثل هذا السيناريو المرعب الذي يتجاوز
السودان وهذه طبعا رساله الى المجتمع
الاقليمي والدولي بان احداث السودان
والحريق الذي يدور الان في العاصمه لن
يتوقف داخل السودان الى اماكن اخرى ويكون
جزء من زعزعه الاستقرار منطقه
حساسه جدا منطقه القرن الافريقي والمنطق
افريقيا هذا التحذير وهذه القراءه السليمه
مئه في المئه مما قاله السيد سولكر من ان
هناك جنوح المفاوضات او ربما رغبه في
التفاوض انا اعتقد ان ذلك من واقع استجابه
الطرفين الان لدعوه للتفاوض حول وقف اطلاق
النار وهي مرحله غير مرحله مرحله الدخول
في مرحله وقف اطلاق النار تمهيدا للمرحله
النهائيه لتسويه النزاع المفاوضات وانا
فعلا على الارض هذا الامر ملحوظ تماما ان
عثر في العمليات العسكريه رغم انها مستمره
في بعض المناطق لكن الحساب في العمليات
العسكريه ويبدو ان الحسابات العسكريه
الطرفين فعلا للبحث عن مسار اخر ان هذا
المسار يمكن
بالتاكيد الان لا نتحدث معك بلغه العسكر
ولكن يعني وفقه ما تعايشونه وما تراقبونه
المعطيات على الارض انه الحرب دخلت في
الاسبوع الثالث هل فعلا بدت ملامح حسم قرب
انتهاء العمليات العسكريه
لا يعني هو كلمه حسم دي بسبب واحد لان
الطبيعه الحرب بنفسها دور الان في السودان
هي ليست حرب بحسومات بمعنى اخر ليست حرب
لاصاله الطرف الاخر يعني كلا من الطرفين
ما اعلنها في بدايه هذه الحرب عن الخطاب
هما والاهداف التي
الاهداف الاستراتيجيه لهذه الحرب لم يكن
فيها استئصال الطرف الاخر يعني
قوات الدعم التاليه قالت انها تريد تغيير
قياده الجيش السوداني الجيش السوداني قال
انه يريد قوات الدعم السريع تحت اداره
الجيش فاذا ليس هناك اصلا حديث عن حسن
بمعنى الطرف الاخر الوصول لهذه الاهداف
التي معلنا من الطرفين طول عن طريق النقاط
وليس عن طريق الضربه القاضيه عن طريق
النقاط يمكن ان يكون المفاوضات واحد من
الوسائل المستخدمه في الوصول الى الاهداف
الصراع في السودان يتواصل لينذر بتحول
البلاد لبؤره توتر اقليمي وجبهه قتال قد
تمتد لدول الجوار توتر صاحبته دعوه دوليه
واقليميه الى ضروره نزع فتيل الازمه
والالتزام بمسار الهدنه واعاده البلاد
لاكمال المسار الديمقراطي المتعثر منذ
سنوات طويله الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن
السودان هذا ما اكده امينها العام انطونيو
غوتيريش الذي دعا الجيش وقوات الدعم
لتغليف لغه الحوار وانهاء الصراع الذي يجب
ان يكون مرتبطا بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار
الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن السودان وستفعل
كل ما بوسعها لتوفير الظروف الامنيه من
اجل تقديم الدعم الانساني للشعب السوداني
ومن نيويورك ايضا اكدت مندوبه بريطانيا في
الامم المتحده ان انها تهدف للحصول على
دعم مجلس الامن لمقترحات الاتحاد الافريقي
فيما يخص الوضع الحالي في السودان الذي
تحول لبقعه جغرافيه ساخنه
هو الحصول على الدعم الكامل من مجلس الامن
لمقترحات ايجاد للتقدم نحو وقف اطلاق نار
ومن ثم العوده للعمليه السياسيه
التطورات الحاصله دفعت باطراف دوليه
واقليميه وعربيه لطرح مبادرات تهدئه بين
الطرفين والتوسط لاتفاق على وقف اطلاق
النار لتعبيد الطريق امام حكومه مدنيه حيث
ان المبعوث الاممي للسودان اشار الى ان
طرفي الصراع في السودان منفتحان على
الحوار فالغراب الدمار وفق مراقبين فان
انقاذ البلاد من الفوضى والدمار وتشكيل
حكومه تكنوقراط تضمن الخروج من الازمه
الحاليه يتطلب تجديد الرياده الدبلوماسيه
من طرف المجموعه الدوليه ومعاقبه الاطراف
التي تسببت في زعزعه استقرار السودان
اذا نعود الى ضيفنا من الخرطوم رئيس تحرير
صحيفه التيار عثمان مرغلي انطلاقا الى كل
هذه المعطيات التي اشرنا اليها وفي سياق
هذه التغطيه حتى هذه اللحظات عثمان اذا
اردنا ان نضع عناوين لابرز ما يجري في
السودان حتى اليوم انطلاقا من موقعكم
كرئيس تحرير لصحيفه الطيار ماذا ستكون
نعم يعني واضح تماما ان هذه الحرب
بالتحديد يعني هي ليست مجرد حرب هو اعاده
تشكيل المشهد السياسي السوداني على وضع
جديد يفتح صفحه جديده يعني لن يكون
السودان بعد هذه الحرب وكما قبل هذه الحرب
وستجري عمليه تشكيل كامله لكل قواعد
اللعبه السياسيه في السودان اعاده صياغه
المفاهيم السياسيه التي عليها هذه اللعبه
السياسيه كل ذلك انا في تقديره يعني ان
المتغيرات او مترتبات ما بعد الحرب هي
المحك وليس الحرب بنفسها لان الحرب الان
استاذ عثمان يعني انهاء المعارك هي اسهل
مرحله في المرحله المقبله
بالتحديد يعني هذا ما اريد ان اقوله الان
الحرب تقريبا انتهت يعني هذه العباره اقول
لها بصوره قويه جدا الحرب تقريبا انتهت
يعني انحسرت بصوره تسير نحو نهايه
والموافقه على المفاوضات وفي اطلاق النار
هي على ان الطرفين الان بالحسابات
العسكريه يشعرون انه لابد ان يذهب الى
الخطوه النهائيه وهي قاعه التفاوض بينهم
ماذا يعني ان العسكريين انهو الاهداف التي
يريدونها هذا الجانب او من ذلك الجانب لكن
يبقى بعد ذلك ماذا ان هذا السؤال صحيح ان
الاجابه عليه دائما تاتي من المشهد
السوداني الذي يجب ان يدرك ما الذي يجب ان
يفعل بعد الحرب بالتاكيد مهما كانت
الحسابات العسكريه المشهد السياسي سيعاد
صياغته بصوره مختلفه تماما الماضي على
سبيل المثال لن تكون هناك عمليه سياسيه
كالتي كانت لن تكون نفس التحالفات
السياسيه لن هناك حتى بعض
المفاهيم السياسيه التي بنى عليها المشهد
السياسي طوال عمر السوداني المستقيم من 67
سنه اذا ما اخذنا الحسابات العسكريه
وربطناها بالحسابات السياسيه في جموع جميع
الحروب التي خاضها السودان كانت الخرطوم
بعيده كثيرا اليوم الى اي حد لن يقبل اي
منتصر من الجانبين ان تذهب مثلا تضحيات
وانصحت تسميتها سدا هكذا وان يكون رقم
الرئيسي في معادله اي سلطه مقبله
نعم يعني هذا صحيح من نظريه اولا صحيح او
اول مره في التاريخ السودان تشهد العاصمه
الخرطوم مثل هذا هذا التيساع صحيح كانت
هناك بعض الانقلابات العسكريه كان فيها
ربع قضاء المعارك التي دارت في نطاق محدود
في بعض العسكريه داخل العاصمه لكن ان تكون
الحرب شامله بهذا المعنى اول مره وربما
فليكن ذلك كفاره كثير من المناطق خاصه
دارفور ولم يكن الناس مع تلك الاحداث في
نفسها وهو عليه الان يعني لاول مره سكان
العاصمه ما معنى الحرب فاذا كانت هذه
الحرب في
دارفور او غيرها او عندما كانت في جنوب
السودان سابقا الان السكان العاصمه معنى
الحرب الحقيقي الذي
يؤثر المواطن داخل بيته داخل الاستقرار
الاسري هذا اول مره لكن بالضروره طبعا هذه
الاحداث في النهايه عسكري ستنحسر سريعا
خلال الايام المقبله ان شاء الله نامل ان
تنحفز باقل الضرار ممكنه ويبقى بعد ذلك
استفاد من هذه الحرب وكيف يمكن اعاده
صياغه الوطن
استاذ عثمان تفضل
على مشهد جديد يعني وصلت اليها هذه الحرب
انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخرطوم رئيس
تحرير صحيفه تيار عثمان مرغني شكرا لك
وفي متابعه الاوضاع الصحيه اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء في السودان ارتفاع عدد القتلى
المدنيين جراء الاشتباكات الى 425 شخصا
واصابه 2021 شخصا اشارت النقابه الى ان 16
مستشفى تعرض للقصف منذ بدايه المواجهات
حيث طالت عمليات القصف مستشفى البراحه في
الخرطوم بحري يوم امس
من جانبيه اكد المسؤول العلمي لهلال
الاحمر السوداني اكد العربيه ان العمل
داخل المستشفيات يجري بامكانيات محدوده
جدا وان هناك حاجه ماسه لوصول المساعدات
من الخارج لتجاوز الاوضاع التي باتت
مترضيه
يعني الوضع الذاتي وببعض المساعدات من بعض
الجهات حتى المنظمات القاتنه بموجود عندها
من مخزون ثابت ومنظم المنظمات بما فيها
حتى الهلال الاحمر السوداني وغيرها كل
المنظمات المعنيه في مساعده لمساعدات
الانسانيه وبتعمل في القطاع الصحي كوضع
طبيعي كجاري بجوارب العمل الانساني بكليه
مخزون طبيعي لكن مخزون الحالات العاديه
للحالات الطارئه في الوضع العادي يعني
فدلوقتي بتتدبر اضافه الى
مساهمات
الاطباء لتشكيلاتهم المختلفه بهيئات
بنقابات
بتنظيمهم الحالي لمجابهه الواقع
من
الخاص وكده لكن عشان نبدا نجابها الموجوده
دي لازم تيجي مساعدات من الخارج
[موسيقى]
حاليا الادويه
اللي خلصت عندنا تماما او على وشك ادويه
الضغط
[موسيقى]
وجد الاحداث الدوحه
انسولين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها يفتش وما خلوه
اي حته فتش عشان تقول اي ما
[موسيقى]
استمرار الاشتباكات يزداد الضغط على
القطاع الصحي في السودان حتى اصبح الحديث
عن انهيار نظام الصحي امرا غير مستبعد
قال رئيس حزب الامه السوداني مبارك الفاضل
قال ان قوه من قوات الدعم السريع اقتحمت
منزله ونشر حزب الامه السودانيه الذي
يتزعمه الفاضل نشر مقطع فيديو اظهر منزله
حيث تعرض للنهب والتخريب
نعود الى مساله الاوضاع الصحيه والطبيه في
السودان نذهب الى الخرطوم معنا من هناك
الدكتوره عطيه عبد الله سكرتير نقابه
اطباء السودان دكتور عطيه مرحبا بك معنا
في هذه الساعه التي نخصصها لتطورات
السودان هل مازال القطاع الصحي والطبي على
مشارف الانهيار ام حصلت خروقات لصالحه
الصحه والعافيه لكل الجرحى وعوده حميدا
لكل المفقودين نعمل
انهيار النظام الصحي اصبح وشيكا نراه راي
العين تدهور تام في الخدمات الطبيه في
المستشفيات نقص حاد في المعينات الطبيه
عدم القدره الى الوصول الى المستشفيات من
الكوادر الطبيه او الاسعاف
نقص حاد في اكياس الدم نقص حاد في
معينات غسيل الكلى نقطه حاد في الادويه
المنقذه للحياه والادويه المستخدمه في
العمليات الجراحيه النقص في كل مكان
يكاد نكون وصلنا الى المرحله الصفريه في
عدد من المعينات الطبيه الضروريه
نحاول جاهدين ان نعمل على تحويل عدد من
الحالات الحرجه الى
الولايات المجاوره ولكن هي الاخرى حتى هي
مخزونات نحن نتخوف من تاتي لحظه لا يستطيع
الكادر الطبي القيام بواجبه المهني
والاخلاقي لانعدام المعينات الضروريه
نقابه اطباء السودان كاولويه اليوم
اعيد السؤال لو سمحتي يعني ما الذي تريده
النقابك اولويه اليوم
نحن نريد كاولويه الان هي الوقف هذه الحرب
فورا ومن ثم فتح ممرات امنه للوصول الى
المستشفيات وايضا فتح كل المخازن الطبيه
داخل وخارج الخرطوم الى وتغذيه المستشفيات
فتح المجال الجوي والبري والبحري للمعينات
الانسانيه من الدول الصديقه والمحبه للشعب
السوداني ايضا نحن نطالب بعدم استهداف
الكوادر الطبيه وعدم استهداف المنشات
الطبيه هي كلها مطالب بسيطه جدا وموضوعيه
وايضا يمكن تطبيقها على ارض الواقع اذا
سبقت النوايا بين طرفي الصراع نعم طيب
دكتور عطيه يعني مثلا الهلال الاحمر من
جانبه يقول بانهم دائما يطالبون بضمانات
لممرات امنه خصوصا للوصول للمصابين وحتى
الجثث الملقاه في الشوارع بالتالي ما الذي
يحصل هل نتحدث عن لا ضمانات حقيقيه
وبالتالي يتم التعرض للجسم الطبي اليوم في
السودان
نحن نتحدث عن لا مبالاه من طرفي الصراع
بكل هذه النداءات التي صدرت من النقابه
ومن كل الشركاء الصحيين في السودان وخارج
السودان نعم هذه الجثث سوف تشكل مشكله
بيئيه وقبل هي مشكله اخلاقيه لان اكرام
الميت
كيف لنا يعني ان نتحدث عن
عن هذه الحرب
هي ستضاف الى تحدياتكم
بالتاكيد وقبلها هنالك مشكله بيولوجيه
حذرنا منها عبر بيان رسمي الان التقدس
النفايات في حد ذاته فقط في هذه الشوارع
تراكم المياه سوف يشكل ايضا اماكن لتوالد
البعوض وغيرها من التي سوف تنتهي بامراض
الملايه وغيرها كل هذه كل هذه معيقات سوف
تكون لها انعكاسات سلبيه على النظام الصحي
الذي يترنح هو قبل هذه المشكلات بكثير
نحن المطالب التي تقدمنا بها مطالب بسيطه
جدا ويمكن تطبيقها اذا صدقت النوايا فقط
ايقاف هذه الحرب بالتاكيد سوف تنهال
المساعدات على الشعب السوداني سوف
استنهاال
الوقفات الشعوب المحبه للسودان وايضا
المنظمات الموجوده في السودان الان هي لا
تستطيع الوصول الى مخازنها
لا يعني
تلقينا هم استعدادهم تماما ووضعوا مخازنهم
يعني تحت تصرف الكوادر الطبيه ولكن كيف
لنا ولهم ان نصل الى هذه المخازن ونعيد
تحريكها من والى المسلسلات نعم دكتور عطيه
هناك ايضا معلومات تتحدث بانه في بعض
المناطق حصلوا على ضمانات وكان الامور
سالكه وامنه للوصول الى المحتاجين من
الرعايه الصحيه وفي بعض المناطق لا
بالتالي كيف يمكن تعميم بروتوكول يحمي
القطاع الصحي والجسم الطبي في السودان في
الوقت الراهن اقله
بالتاكيد
نحن لم نسمع عن اي ضمانات حتى الان منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب حتى الان نحن لم نسمع عن
اي ضمانات كل الذين يتحدثون عن ضمانات نحن
حتى كانت تحت رعايه الامور المتحده في
السودان هي لم نرى لها اي ضمانات لذلك هي
فشلت قبل ان تبدا
الذي يجب ان يحدث نحن نريد فتح ممرات امنه
ونريد هدنه
بضمانات بدون ضمانات لا نستطيع تحريك
الكوادر لانه حتى الان نحن فقدنا 13 من
الشهداء الكوادر الطبيه نحن فقدنا اكثر من
15 مستشفى تم قصها نحن فقدنا اكثر من 19
مستشفى
كل هذه عوامل وارقام كبيره جدا لذلك بدون
هذه الضمانات لا احد يستطيع التعميم خروج
ودخول الكوادر الى المستشار نحن الان نعمل
على فتح المستشفيات الطرفيه تشغيلها
بالكوادر القريبه حتى لا يكونوا هم ايضا
عرض
لاي اعمال اخرى كذلك نحن انعدام الامن حتى
حول حوالين هذه المسلسلات كمستشفى البان
جديد يعني حوله عدد من حالات النهب
والسرقه وايضا التعدي على على الكوادر
الطبيه والمواطنين حاله انعدام الامن
وانعدام اللا دوله هو مشكله خطيره جدا في
حركه الكوادر الطبيه نعم انا اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من الخرطومه الدكتور عطيه عبد الله
عطيه سكرتير نقابه اطباء السوداني
تفاقم الاوضاع الطبيا عكس على قطاع
الادويه حيث تتفاقم ازمه نقص الادويه في
الخرطوم مع استمرار المواجهات المسلحه
وحذر تجمع الصيادله المهنيين بالسودان
حذروا من كارثه صحيه بسبب عمليات نهب
الصيدليات وشركات ومخازن الادويه في مدن
العاصمه الثلاث بالتزامن مع اغلاق عدد
كبير من الصيدليات في ام درمان حاليا
الادويه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك يا ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه اللي بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي
او الادويه التاثير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
ديل الناس طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي
الادويه دي اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف
العاديه فيها شح والان المشكله بقت اكبر
بالاضافه للفوط الصحيه
للسيدات تكاد تكون الان ما موجوده خالص
كمان مشكله الالبان عند الاطفال دي مشكله
كارثه حقيقيه الان الالبان غير موجوده
وجدت الاحداث الدوحه
انسانين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها تفتشوا ما خلا
اي حته فتش عشان تقول لي ما
خلينا صيدليه ما لقينا ما خلينا حتى ما
لقينا
[موسيقى]
وعلى وقع استمرار الاشتباكات وغياب اي
بوادر لحل قريب وصف برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي لوضع الانساني في السودان
بالكارثي
شوارع الخرطوم شبه خاليه لا امن ولا امان
اما اسواقها يكبل الكساد ايدي التجار فيها
فالمعروض قليل والطلب شبه معدوم
البطاطس ملام بعشره وسبعه الاف الان شباب
اقتصاد السودان صعد على سكه خسائر لا يمكن
التصور ابعادها وبات شبح المجاعه يهدد كل
من تقطعت بهم سبل الخروج منه برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي وصف الوضع الانساني في
البلاد بالكارتي مؤكدا انه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال اولا لتمكين ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه بامان
وضع انساني يزداد كل يوم سوءا وتحيط به
مخاوف من ارتفاع جنني في اسعار المواد
الغذائيه والوقود معنى فادي الاموال
والامدادات الاساسيه وتعطل الانظمه
المصرفيه
حالهم بات غايه في السوق والتردي واصعب
مهامهم تامين قوتهم اليومي وحاجاتهم
الغذائيه حيث شهدت اسعار السلع
الاستهلاكيه الضروريه في العاصمه الخرطوم
ارتفاعا كبيرا ومفاجئا مع اعتبره
السودانيون غير مبرر في حين عزاه البعض
الى استغلال التجار لظروف المواطنين
الصعبه
اندلاع الحرب جدد المخاوف من انزلاق
الاقتصاد السوداني نحو الانهيار الشامل
فمع دخول الحرب الاسبوع الثالث واستمرار
عمليات الاجلاء سترتفع احتمالات اصابه
النشاط الاقتصادي بالشلل وستنجر البلاد
نحو مصير مظلم واكبر خطرا
اياد حمود العربيه
[موسيقى]
اما الان فنذهب معكم الى جوله على ابرز
الاخبار الدوليه في اخر تطورات الاوضاع في
مدينه بخموت حيث تدور المعارك منذ اشهر
قال المتحدث باسم القوات الاوكرانيه
قال ان بلاده لا تزال تسيطر على طريق
امداد هام مؤذن الى المدينه مؤكدا لوسائل
الاعلام محليه ان الوضع في بخموت لا يزال
صعبا بسبب محاولات القوات الروسيه للسيطره
على طريق الحياه المؤدي للمدينه الا ان
قوات بلاده لن تسمح للروس بقطع الخدمات
اللوجسيه للجيش الاوكراني
اكد رئيس الاوكراني
على ان قواته جاهزه لشن الهجوم المضاد رغم
عدم استلام الطائرات المقاتله من الغرب
بصراحه كانت الطائرات ستساعدنا كثيرا في
الهجوم المضاد لكننا نتفهم ايضا انه لا
يمكن ادراجها ضمن خططنا في الوقت الحالي
وهذا هو السبب في اننا سنبدا الامر قبل
استلام طائرات اف 16 او انواع اخرى روسيا
مطمئنه لاعتقادها اننا ما زلنا بحاجه الى
شهرين لبدء الهجوم المضاد بعد التدريب على
الطائرات نقول هذا لن يحدث سنبدا الهجوم
ونمضي قدما لكن في الوقت نفسه هذا مهم
للغايه لاستلام الطائرات المقاتله الغربيه
قال متحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قوات موسكو قصفت موقع القياده والمراقبه
للطائرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه قربه منطقه
خرسون والحقت وحدات المدفعيه اضرارا
بنيرانها بموقع القياده والمراقبه ومركز
التحكم للطائرات بدون طياره تابعه للواء
124 من قوات الدفاع الاقليميه التابعه
مضيفا ان قوات موسكو دمرت مستودع تخزين
ذخيره والمعدات قرب المدينه الساحليه جنوب
البلاد موضحا ان القصف الروسي اسفل عن
مقتل 30 شخصا من صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه
وتدمير اكثر من عشر مركبات قتاليه مصفحه
من جانبه تعهد الرئيس الاوكراني وفولو
بمحاسبه روسيا عقب سقوط عشرات القتلى
والجرحى جراء قصفها لمدينه عمان
الاوكرانيه
سنفعل كل ما هو ممكن للضمان محاسبه الدوله
الارهابيه على ما فعلته في اقرب وقت ممكن
اي شخص يعد لمثل هذه الهجمات الصاروخيه لا
يسعه الا ان يعرف انه سيصبح شريكا في
القتل وارهابيا ليس فقط اولئك الذين يعطون
الاوامر انتم جميعا ارهابيون وقتله وتجد
معاقبتكم جميعا
تعتزم كوريا الشماليه تعزيز الرضع العسكري
ضد كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
منتقده اتفاق القمه الذي عقد هذا الاسبوع
بين البلدين بشان تعزيز الرد الموسع
الامريكي ووصفته بانه نتاج سياسه عدائيه
شائنه
قد وافقت على نشر غواصات مسلحه نوويا في
كوريا الجنوبيه وشاكسول في التخطيط النووي
لمواجهه التعديلات النوويه من جارتها
الشماليه
افادت وكاله بلومبرج بان دول الاوروبيه
باتت تضع قيودا جديده على الصادرات
والاستثمارات الصينيه بسبب استيائها من
علاقات بكين الوثيقه مع رئيس بوتين مشيره
الى ان دولا مثل المانيا وايطاليا تدرسان
وضع ضوابط التي اعتمدتها الولايات المتحده
على التصدير والاستثمار لاستهداف الصين
ووفقا للوكاله فان واشنطن والاتحاد
الاوروبي تعملان على تطوير ادوات جديده
لابطاء تقدم الصين في عده مجالات تشمل
اشباه الموصلات والدفاع مضيفه انهما
يناقشان وضع ضوابط على التصدير وتشديد
الرقابه على استثمارات وزياده التعاون في
مجال المواد الحيويه
قبل ايام من معاوده الكنيست لعمله بعد
عطله تجددت الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل ضد
مشروع اصلاح النظام القضائي والذي اقترحته
الحكومه برئاسه بنيامين نتنياهو وتجمع بين
150 شخصا الى 200 الف شخص وفق تقديرات
وسائل الاعلام محليه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اغلقت تركيا مجالها الجوي امام طائرات
شركه فلايوان ارمينيا دون سابق انذار حسب
ما ذكرت وكاله ارمان بريس للانباء عن رئيس
مجلس اداره الشركه وقال ارام انانيان رئيس
مجلس اداره شركه الارمنيه انه لاسباب غير
مفهومه ودون اي مبرر واضح الغت سلطات
الطيران التركيه تصريحا كانت قد منحته
لشركه فلايوان ارمينيا لتسيير رحله الى
اوروبا عبر المجال الجوي التركي
اعلن رجل الاعمال ملياردير ايلون ماسك عن
خطه لمنصه تويتر تسمح لنشريل وسائل عالميه
بتقاضي بدل من المستخدمين على اساس قراءه
كل مقاله على حده وبنقره واحده قال ماسك
ان الخطه ستمكن المستخدمين الذين لم
يشتركوا شهريا بدفع بدل اعلى مقابل قراءه
كل مقاله وبشكل عابر وان الامر سيشكل
مكسبا رئيسيا للمؤسسات الاعلاميه والجمهور
ضرب اعصار قوي منطقه بان بيتش جاردنز في
ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه وادى الطقس
القاسي الى قلب السيارات وتحطيم النوافذ
والاشجار اوضحت السلطات انه لم يتم
الابلاغ عن وقوع اي اصابات
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الساعه الاخباريه التي
خصصنا جلها للحديث عن التطورات في السودان
التغطيه مستمره وجديد الاخبار والمعلومات
مع زميلي نايف الاحمر بعد قليل الى اللقاء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات